salut aujourd'hui je vous parle d'une
technique très efficace pour la mémoire
je parle bien sûr évidemment des flash
cards dans une vidéo assez récent que
j'ai abordé cette technique pour
apprendre et je me suis aperçu dans les
commentaires que vous la connaissiez pas
forcément alors on va corriger ça
génériques
tout commence avec herman et bingo c'est
un philosophe allemand qui un matin
s'est réveillé et a fait il dit donc est
ce que la mémoire et l'apprentissage
pourrait pas se développer par des
méthodes cognitive un petit peu
différente et suite à cette brillante
question il est le premier à mettre en
place des méthodes expérimentales pour
comprendre le fonctionnement de la
mémoire et pour ça il fait des tests où
il fait apprendre des choses qui n'ont
pas forcément de sens comme des suites
de lettres qu'ils ne veulent rien dire
il s'est dans les années 70 que
sébastien leitner qui lui était un
scientifique allemand met au point les
cartes mémoire que nous appellerons
ensuite les flash cards en se basant
principalement sur les travaux de ce bon
herrmann oui jeudi son prénom qui est
plus facile à prononcer le nom de
famille est aussi sur le principe de la
répétition espaces et le principe est
très simple il faut avoir des cartes ou
des fiches cartonnées ou des petites
cartes ou d'un côté on met une question
et de l'autre côté on met la réponse est
le but c'est de se servir d'un principe
dont je vous ai déjà parlé qui est le
fait de repasser fréquemment et
régulièrement sur le chemin mental qu'on
a créé pour creuser ça et est comment
dire le rendre plus profond dans la
mémoire le fonctionnement de base c'est
le suivant vous prenez une boîte avec
plusieurs compartiments dans la boîte le
plus possible de lier cette c'est plutôt
pas mal et vous mettez toutes vos cartes
mémoire flash cards dans le premier
compartiment
quand vous allez travailler regarde vous
prenez une des cartes dans le premier
compartiment vous lisez la question vous
chercher la réponse dans votre tête vous
vérifiez si c'est la bonne réponse vous
la mettez dans le compartiment suivant
si c'est la mauvaise réponse vous la
remettez dans ce compartiment là pour
être sûr de pouvoir y revenir et chaque
jour vous faites ça avec les cartes qui
se trouve dans le premier slow up dans
le premier compartiment
par contre tous les 2 jours vous le
faites également sur les cartes qui sont
dans le deuxième compartiment tous les 3
jours vous faites également dans celles
qui sont dans le troisième compartiment
etc etc jusqu'à sept compartiments
ce qui fait qu'en fonction des choses
que vous savez déjà vous allez les
revoir de manière plus ou moins espacées
jusqu'à temps de les mettre dans la
mémoire long terme pour recommande
également une boîte qui ne sera vu
qu'une fois par semaine et une autre qui
sera vu qu'une fois par mois et pourquoi
pas une boîte qui ne sera vu que tous
les six mois c'est à dire que celle qui
est dans la carte tous les un mois vous
la prenez vous regardez la question vous
trouvez la réponse vous la mettez sur la
boîte six mois sinon vous l'a laissé
dans la boîte un mois pour être sûr de
la revoir le mois prochain avec ce
système vous pouvez apprendre de
nouvelles langues des formules de maths
des dates historiques du vocabulaire des
noms de médicaments tout ce que vous
voulez et si vous
rencontre tous les vecteurs cognitive
vous pouvez construire vos flash cards
également avec des dessins de la couleur
c'est encore plus efficace moi je m'en
suis servi à l'époque où j'ai appris ma
première table de rappel je m'étais fait
des flash cards avec d'un côté le dessin
et de l'autre côté le nombre ou le
chiffre et si vous n'avez pas ce que
c'est une table de rappel regarder dans
ma playlist mémoire j'en ai parlé
plusieurs fois cette année je vous
recommande de faire les questions les
plus simples possibles avec les réponses
les plus simples possibles
les flash cards sont pas fait pour
retenir des paragraphes entiers plein de
mots ou une numération n'est pas facile
à dire et dubé relations chaque carte
doit dédier à une seule chose donc vous
pouvez simplifier au maximum si on prend
le fameux 15 115 la réunion vous auriez
pu mettre marignan d'à côté qu'un 115 de
l'autre puisque c'est vous qui les
construisent et vous même vous savez à
quoi se réfère évidemment prioriser
l'ordre des cartes par l'ordre
d'importance des choses que vous voulez
apprendre j'ai trouvé un site qui
s'appelle study blue qui permet de les
faire en ligne ou sur son smartphone il
ya une version gratuite et une version
payante mais chercher sur internet il
doit bien y avoir d'autres sites pour ça
d'ailleurs si vous connaissez vous même
des versions gratuites sur sa sur
smartphone ou sur l'ordinateur pour les
faire de manière dématérialisée
n'hésitez pas à nous dire dans les
commentaires à elle partagée avec
l'ensemble des mental merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que vous
trouverez ça plus clair concernant cet
outil que j'adore utiliser penser
également avant de partir à vous abonner
à la chaîne puisque le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour depuis bientôt trois
cents jours oui ma petite dame bientôt
300 jours alors rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
et